primer día de exposición universal y el
público se amontona en la entrada
aplazada un año por la pandemia de kobe
19 la expo de dubai 2020 es el mayor
evento internacional desde que estalló
la crisis sanitaria también es la
primera vez que la expo se celebra en
oriente medio por lo que el emirato
quiere dejar al mundo con la boca
abierta
esa fue la intención de la ceremonia de
apertura
el gran solista chino lang lang abrió el
baile los espectáculos se sucedieron
también los grandes artistas
actuó la estrella del pop británico
ellie goulding y el tenor italiano
andrea bocelli
[Música]
el joven príncipe heredero promete la
exposición universal más excepcional de
la historia
y
hoy el mundo entero se reúne en los
emiratos árabes unidos
inauguramos juntos con la bendición de
dios la exposición universal de dubai
la
cual la uabjo
pero es difícil de hacer olvidar el
boicot del legislativo europeo aunque la
mayoría de los países europeos
participan en el acontecimiento el
parlamento se posicionó en contra de los
emiratos por sus violaciones de los
derechos humanos detrás del escenario la
realidad es crítica hay más de 25
prisioneros políticos una decena de
personas detenidas de forma indefinida
la libertad de expresión está limitada
hay desigualdad frente a la ley la
justicia emiratí no considera iguales a
hombres y mujeres las relaciones
extramatrimoniales y entre personas del
mismo sexo están perseguidas la pena de
muerte está vigente y no son seis meses
de festividad que harán callar a las ong
ni una exposición universal que cambiara
el país
[Música]